foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
age separation confirmed Dragon
separation confirmed
[Music]
stage one is transonic landing like that
deployed
and Falcon 9 has landed
hey everyone and happy Friday my name is
Sonia srivastava and I'm a structures
engineer here at SpaceX I'll be your
host for today's starlink Mission which
marks spacex's 20th launch of the year
and 219. and 219th overall mission to
date on your screen is a live view of
our Falcon 9 rocket at space launch
complex 40 at Cape Canaveral Florida
currently weather is green and the range
is ready to support a t0 of 11 43 a.m
Eastern Time
the teams are currently tracking no
issues with the vehicle or spacecraft
in a little bit we should see the strong
back clamp arms opening up and pulling
away from the vehicle
all right strongback lower this weekend
there we have a great view of the strong
back clamp arms
and in a few seconds we should see those
plant Farms beneath the fairing open up
and then the strong back should begin to
retract away from the rocket
can see those pulling away
the strong back is also called The
Transporter director or te which is how
we break over the vehicle from
horizontal to vertical and how we route
propellant to the vehicle before liftoff
you can see those clamp arms are now
fully opened and the strong back will
shortly begin to pull away from the
rocket
you can see that strong back is going to
pull away
and coming up next at T minus three
minutes we should hear that stage one
has completed liquid oxygen loading
day to unlock the complete
and at T minus three minutes Falcon 9's
first stage is fully loaded with rp1 and
locks and we're awaiting completion of
Glocks load on the second stage in about
50 seconds from now
the booster you see on screen today went
through a successful static fire attempt
yesterday
static fires are an opportunity to fully
run the engines with locks and rp1 to
ensure the propellant systems are
functioning as we want them to if you
didn't know we use two types of
propellant on Falcon 9 rp1 stands for
Rocket repellent 1 which is a rocket
grade kerosene and lock stands for
liquid oxygen so that's what you keep
hearing over the nuts
you can probably see those white clouds
coming off of the side of the booster
that is gas above the Lox tank that's
venting out to maintain pressure inside
of the tanks
foreign
we have good confirmation there that the
second stage is now full of locks which
means that Falcon 9 is now fully loaded
with 1 million pounds of fuel and liquid
oxygen
you can see that the booster is covered
in a good amount of soot and that's
because it has nine flights under its
belt having previously taken multiple
trips to the ISS with two CRS missions
two crew missions in addition to
supporting the Turks at 5B utosat
hotbird 13g mpower a and two
back-to-back starlink missions after
liftoff and Stage separation the booster
is scheduled to land on our drone ship a
shortfall of Gravitas which is currently
located off the Florida coast in the
Atlantic Ocean
we just heard that the flight computers
have taken over the countdown and the
rocket is now on internal power in a few
seconds we should hear confirmation from
the launch director
LD go for launch
as you just heard the launch director
has given the final go to proceed for
launch let's sit back and watch as
Falcon 9 takes our 56 Starling
satellites into space
30 seconds
15 seconds
Eagles pitching done range
at t plus 30 seconds F9 has successfully
lifted off from space launch complex 40
from the cape at 11 43 a.m Eastern Time
[Music]
mod tire pressures are nominal
power and telemetry
[Music]
supersonic
you just heard the call out that Falcon
9 is supersonic which means the vehicle
is traveling faster than the speed of
sound
[Music]
Max q and there you just heard that call
out from Max Q which is the point at
which the vehicle experiences the
greatest amount of external stress as it
ascends through the Earth's atmosphere
[Music]
we're now about one minute away from a
series of events Nico stage sup scs-1
and fairing separation Mikko or main
engine cutoff is when all nine of the
Merlin engines on the first stage shut
down stage stage separation is when the
first and second stages separate from
one another scs-1 or second engine start
one is where we light the Merlin vacuum
engine on the second stage and fairing
separation is when the two fairing
halves separate and fall away from the
second stage keep an eye out for these
events happening in quick succession
we go
stage separation confirmed
and back ignition
and you just saw that we confirmed Mikko
stage separation and ses1 will be coming
up shortly on varying separation
separation
and there we just heard and saw those
two fairing halves separating and
falling away from the second stage both
of the fairing halves that flew on
today's Mission are flight proven with
one half flying for the sixth time and
the other its seventh we'll be
attempting to recover both fairing
halves using our recovery vessel duck
just as a reminder on the left hand side
of your screen is the Falcon 9 first
stage
and on the right is the mvac ignition
that you can see glowing bright orange
as it's carrying our starlink satellites
to their desired orbit
we also just heard a call out that stage
one and stage two are both following
nominal trajectories currently the first
stage is on its way back to Earth
towards our drone ship a shortfall of
Gravitas the mbac engine attached to the
second stage is continuous burn which
will last for another five minutes or so
acquisition of signal Bermuda
for those of you who are just joining us
we had an on-time liftoff at 11 43 a.m
eastern time from slick 40. today's
starlink Mission marks spacex's 219th
Mission overall and 20th Mission just
this year
a beautiful view of planet Earth on the
left hand side of your screen and on the
right hand side behind stage two
if you look on the bottom corners of
your screen you can see the speed and
altitude of both the first and second
stages
as a reminder starlink is a satellite
internet constellation designed and
manufactured by SpaceX to provide high
speed low latency internet to people
living in remote and Rural locations
around the globe today we're sending
another 56 satellites to space on
today's mission
stage one entry burn startup
there's a call out for stage one entry
burn stage one which we also call the
booster has relit three of its engines
is saved engines 1 5 and 9 to slow it
down for atmospheric re-entry
stage one entry burn shutdown
two FTS is safe that the entry burn on
the first stage has completed the first
stage used to launch our 56 Sterling
satellites into space today is flying
for its 10th time having supported two
CRS missions two crew missions Turks at
five feet equals on a nominal trajectory
utilize that hot bird 13 g m power a and
two Starling commissions we have one
more burn coming up on the first stage
which is the landing burn and should be
coming up in about one minute
the center engine E9 specifically is the
engine that relights for landing burn to
slow it down before it touches on the
Drone ship
stage one transonic
there's that call that the first stage
is transonic which means it's traveling
near the speed of sound coming up next
we have Landing burn which should start
in about 15 seconds from now
stage one landingbird
and there's confirmation that the stage
one Landing burn has started in
preparation for touchdown on our drone
ship a shortfall effect of Gravitas
they drone lending leg deploy
Stage One Lending confirmed
Falcon 9 has successfully landed marking
the 10th successful Landing for this
booster and we're now waiting second
engine cutoff coming up in a few seconds
inspected lots of signals Bermuda
nominal orbit insertion
and if you heard those call-outs we had
successful zico and nominal orbital
insertion so with confirmation of
successful first stage landing and
second engine cutoff that's going to
wrap up our coverage for today today's
Landing marks our 181st overall Landing
of an orbital class rocket including
Falcon 9 and Falcon heavy missions and
our 219th overall mission to date be
sure to check out our social media Pages
for a confirmation of Starling satellite
deployment and thank you all for
watching and we hope you have a great
weekend
[Music]
thank you